welcome back to Piers Morgan and sense
the revelations about disgraced movie
director Harvey Weinstein's abusive
women sparked a global Reckoning with
predatory male Behavior but five years
on from what became known as the metoo
movement there's a growing backlash some
influential people argue it's become
divisive putting the Sexes against each
other with an assumption of male guilt
even many young men feeling marginalized
the reason you'd be two people the
Forefront of that backlash albeit with
very different styles of rationales he's
psychologist Dr Jordan Peterson
people have been after me for a long
time by because I've been speaking to
disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is
and earlier this week I spoke to Andrew
Tate the so-called toxic male influencer
who's now banned from social media the
full explosive interview is tomorrow
night but here's a little taster of that
I believe that confident strong man who
stand up and protect and provide for
women are a good thing for the world and
a good Force for the world and I don't
think that I put a magic spell on
anybody I think there's a whole bunch of
men in the world who understands my
value and if if men grow up to be like
me you're gonna have a whole bunch of
people with no criminal record dedicated
athletes who protect and provide for the
people close to them are fantastic for
the economy and we're and I'm not I'm
certainly not the worst influence out
here peers
well clips of both of those interviews
have exploded online literally millions
of people have been viewing them uh
Jordan Peterson for example the whole
interview has been viewed five and a
half million times on our YouTube
channels rightly or wrongly there's
clearly a huge Groundswell of of
interest at the very least in their
views if not support so it was me too an
overdue Reckoning or has it become a
damaging battle in a raging culture War
Isabel still with me political
journalist Ava 17 on conservative
commentator young man who agrees with
Peterson and Andrew take Connor Thomas
and Connor uh welcome to the show let's
start with you
I found it very interesting interviewing
Jordan Peterson Andrew Tate both very
controversial characters in different
ways both positioned as a kind of kings
of toxic masculinity I certainly didn't
think Jordan Peterson was that and when
it came to Andrew Tate I couldn't really
conclude after 90 minutes of grilling
him I gave him quite a hard time
um I couldn't really conclude what he
had done that was so bad that he had to
be expunged from social media life
altogether but it showed me the
sensitivity around all this and if any
man now behaves in a way that looks like
it's toxic masculinity bang they're
expunged is in that process masculinity
itself getting expunged and demonized I
would say so I mean I'm sure that that
you'll have this experience with your
own relationships peers and that women
if you say something controversial
whether it's uh something on the piece
inside of the spectrum or on the Tate
side of the spectrum a little bit more
explosive or a little bit more academic
some women are very much drawn to a man
who can be a bit more confrontational
say exactly what he thinks it's the
verbal new version of what Gladiators
used to do in the arena way back well
certainly I think Ava and Isabel are
laughing because they know that they're
drawn to me in that way because of my
combative nature but Ava you're smirking
and laughing I mean there's a serious
point a lot of young men feel they're
getting disenfranchised by Society
they're all being over demonized that
any attempt to be the traditional male
figure is now being rubbished and and
called toxic well I mean if you really
felt that and you really went out there
and you weren't alpha male then you
wouldn't be bothered about a bunch of
women telling you that you were
like Andrew if you get banned from I
mean he's hardly been canceled he was on
your program which is on National
Television but it's the only platform
actually he's had for a long time
because all the social media companies
banned him literally banned him he had
his email gone his Google gone his
Facebook gone it all went down like
Domino's well he's still on there very
very prolific on there I can't move for
Clips yeah but they're not generated by
him now well but that's been for quite
something but should he be punished that
way but what it what is what is punished
what it's punished is where companies
take a decision which in my view in this
case was perverse because they still
allow for example the Ayatollah of Iran
to have Twitter account yes so there's a
there's no consistency here at all well
but however we love a bit of free market
I'm sure you do judging by that suit
which is lovely
um but you know social media companies
are private companies
but over your point about you know if if
men were that Alpha then they wouldn't
be that bothered by this doesn't really
help us when it comes to boys growing up
and that is one of my worries that for
teenage boys now they are so terrified
of the consequences of putting a foot
out of line it was hard enough being a
young teenager working out how things
are working out how to do dating and all
of that without the terror that if you
touch in the wrong place at the wrong
time you may find that your whole life
is destroyed too much well I I like that
boy
I think that men should be frightened I
think you feel better
it's an interesting thing that you see I
would say that that attitude actually is
part of the problem too that is that's
to me toxic femininity that is saying
you should all be terrified you men if
you put one assaulting well I I I think
we all understand what sexual assault
what Isabelle's talking about is that
young teenage clumsiness in many cases
which is now being re-categorized as
assault is that a problem not being
re-categorized as a soul it's always
been assault it's just we're finally
talking about I don't agree with that
it's ridiculous teenage boy fumbling
with teenage girls in most cases assault
do you remember Aziz I'm sorry right
half the heels of me too half the heels
of Harvey Weinstein rightly being
dragged through the courts and he should
have got way worse than just prison time
in my opinion as his own sorry had a
consensual relationship with a woman she
felt a bit awkward and afterwards
rescinded consent and he was London and
he had his no I'm with you on that one
then why should men be afraid of that
because he didn't touch her without
consent did he nobody
supposed to navigate this the whole
thing I'm thinking of my teenage son you
know he's 14 15. what's he supposed to
say would you mind if I'm Isabel you are
an extremely strong woman I know in your
house you're teaching them the
difference between assault and then of
course but what we're talking about is
it's been very interesting watching the
metoo movement and the time's up
movement how it's all developed because
a lot of very bad people Harvey
Weinstein and others got their due
comeuppance we can all agree with that
yeah this is not even something to be
debated we're really talking about the
Gray Line right where is that Gray Line
how do you navigate it when you're an
experienced adult and you've been around
the block in many ways you can navigate
that much more intelligently and with
emotional intelligence then you can if
you're a teenage boy and I think the
point Isabelle makes is a good one I've
got three sons in their 20s I've always
taught them to be respectful to women I
believe they are but I do think it's
really hard for a 16 17 year old boy now
in this environment to know
some kind of physical relationship with
a woman those good boys are all
terrified I know that from talking to my
son he's just like I'm just not going
there is that healthy yes I think it is
actually I think it's better to not have
a physical relationship than to have one
that could ruin a woman's life but then
how do they ever start well don't if
you're not 100 sure we're gonna have a
bunch of Newton Boys we actually do have
that gen Z is having far less sexual
relationships true and young people have
stopped having sex I agree with the
first part of your sentence actually if
you're not willing to have a sexual
relationship with clearly defined lines
don't have one and so I actually told my
my mates at University don't sleep
around with girls one girls don't bring
a guy home that you don't know it's
capable of two guys don't bring a girl
home if you think that possibly she
could have a false accusation against
you can I make another Point here which
I find I mean look that census to me
when I was your age right how old are
you uh 23 23. when I was your age the
idea you would even have that sort of
thought process yeah I wouldn't have
those sort of mates that would ever
cross
is there a certain is there a certain
Purity here I'm detecting in a certain
type of feminist who thinks that they're
all unimpeachable and that this is all
one-way traffic and the only men can be
toxic no because I gotta I've got to
Enlighten you I've met quite a few women
in my life who are pretty toxic
themselves and I don't see the debate
being framed around that at all no but
the point is is that we're still in a
situation where only five percent of
rape cases actually even go to Toronto
which is ridiculous but that's the
extreme end of it yeah there's an idea
you're talking about I'm talking about
but even we can all agree that's wrong
we can all agree that's wrong but okay
so even on the extreme end of it rape
doesn't even go to trial if you if
you're assaulted and that is
life-changing what happened to Rose
McGowan yes with Harvey I know Rose well
and she didn't get her but even we'd all
agree about that well I think what what
I sent a shudder through all of our
spines from your mouth today is the line
that all young men should be terrified
of any physical contact well no you
didn't say it sure
on something completely nebulous okay
can I ask you this if you were going to
go if you were going to take someone to
bed and you weren't 100 sure that they
wanted to go to bed with you would you
go no I would not do that but the point
was because he's Ansari was Shaw for
example and then later she went and
published a long piece right as she
regretted it and lumped him in with
Harvey once I mean do you feel do you
feel any other Ava's gone too far do you
think the pendulum has gone too far at
all no no I don't think it's gone far
enough actually really I still I don't
think we've brought anything into
schools to your point we haven't brought
any teaching into school about what is
assault what isn't if you're worried
about like 16 year old boys not
understanding what it is bring in sexual
health lessons the idea sorry the idea
that you can teach rapists not to rape
is insane because they already know what
do you mean okay right you're saying if
boys wouldn't know what's assault and
what is it yeah right okay the idea that
rather than
um taking the power out of someone who
can make a full accusation is what
they're actually most of them are
concerned about specifically my friends
for example who would never dream of
doing something like that but then what
the feminists fail to understand is you
can educate
did you not identify yourself as a
feminine study no I didn't actually okay
sorry so then that's what peers labeled
actually I called you a toxic feminist
okay
yeah fair enough but you cannot if a
rapist is willing to violate the law so
violently you cannot teach him out of
that all you can have is very harsh
punishments to deter because you're
talking about the Gray Line and the gray
line is that parties of not
understanding that when a woman is so
inebriated that she can't stand up boys
need to understand that is well that's a
difference even something else Ava I
would like to know whether you accept
that women and particularly teenage
girls and young women sometimes give out
pretty mixed signals they give out mixed
messages they're not even sure what they
want at any given time I think we're
victim blaming I do things
every single of your body knows what she
just said women can sometimes
messages come on I mean I mean sure I'm
sure but I'm talking about a song so how
are you supposed I don't think any of us
disagree about assault we're talking
about the far grayer line of young
teenage fumblers
they've all stopped having sex because
they are actually terrified and I think
it's a great shame if they're terrified
into actually having no physical
interaction with exactly
because I make one other point which is
this whole thing of dredging up
allegations that are 10 or 20 years old
I think is absolutely awful because it's
a he said she said it's impossible to
prove and there are people whose careers
are and their lives are completely
ruined by allegations that are bought a
decade or more after the event now
obviously if the person was a minor at
the time of the incident of the alleged
incident I don't think you're saying
that we should bring up historic assault
claims
women who would have been too afraid to
confront it at the time because they
were too young or too powerless
I would actually size slightly with over
here in the sense I don't have a problem
with historic crimes for example Harvey
Weinstein they're all historical points
there actually for someone like Harvard
yes because someone like Harvey wants
team should there be a color point or
should the victims who were all bullied
and scared
I think it depends on the severity of
the allegation obviously if it's
something you know it's a rape case or
something but if it is a you know he put
his right hands on my knee you're
talking about the journalist movement
bravely came forward and told about how
cabinet ministers have touched the
ministry which was horrendous
to me I mean what 20 years later yeah
sexual harassment culture that is in
Westminster and is still really
pervasive at the moment well the good
thing is we're of all which complete
agreement after five years of the me too
movement uh but it's it's interesting
isn't it so we've got lots of different
views here it is complicated I think and
I I would I would argue but maybe a man
shouldn't argue this at all but I would
argue the pendulum may have swung a
little too far you don't think it's
swung far enough you probably are on my
side you probably are too but I'm not
sure we should really be taking sides
either it's a complex Minefield and I
think that the when you start using
phrases you should be terrified nobody
should be terrified on any side of this
I don't think unless they have a
Criminal Intent uh but good debate thank
you very much for coming in we
appreciate it